ces manteaux guy avec l'acteur et de
scrutin il faut j'ai fait barrage
est ce que j'ai donné à manger aux chats
mais ouais tout le temps ben oui c'était
tu repenses à son organisation de ta
journée parce que là c'est moche au
boulot mais un moment donné il faut que
ça avance dans le passé ça niveau
orgasme moi j'en ai pas souvent je suis
pas là pour pour avoir un orgasme cela
pour transmettre des émotions quand on
fait un film de comédie les gens ils
sont là pour rire quoi mais sur moment
ils sont tellement fait la prise que les
acteurs qu'ils le font il rigole même
plus à leur propre aux blagues et moi je
suis pas là pour prendre mon pied et mon
pied je vais le prendre autrement quand
il ya des accusations bas est
généralement à l'orgasme qui
l'accompagnent il est en général
beaucoup moins intense qu'un orgasme
privé parce que marc offense à autre
chose on pense à se placer à la lumière
dana
après il ya aussi des défauts ses
accusations entre autres par l'ademe il
ya de plus en plus d'acteurs aussi que
maintenant qu'ils qui se font qu'ils
sont des érections en fait à base de oui
voilà enfin une crise qu'ils soient
injectés en fait un produit qui va créer
une érection mécanique et qui du coup
bah oui ou pas du tout de problème
d'excitation sexuelle
quand tu dois banc dès 6 heures il est
vraiment moins de fouiller le net c'est
pas possible c'est inhumain de bande et
6h plupart du temps c'est à wels et sur
les tournages ça doit y aller dans tous
les sens se tourne qui doit s'éclater
met pas du tout en fait c'est un travail
est pour moi la base c'est surtout la
prévention auprès des mineurs que voilà
c'est pas comme ça qu'on le premier
rapport que tu avec ta petite copine
c'est pas en utilisant les cheveux et en
lui mettant des claques on n'est pas là
pour faire une compétition on est là
pour c'est du fantasme
c'est simplement ça et surtout martelé
et tout en tout temps le consentement
déjà ce qui est important de souligner
c'est que les toutes les scènes pornos
sont scriptés avant le tournage il va y
avoir un briefing on va dire voilà on va
faire telle position dans l ordre etc
et après on on sait vraiment quand on
est professionnel ça ne s'est pas tout à
fait pareil pour des débutants mais on
sait comment se positionner et c'est
donc forcément quand on a l'habitude de
travailler
les briefings vont plus vite donc il ya
un dialogue on n'est pas vraiment mais
vous n'est jamais livrés à nous-mêmes
l'organisation d'un tournage c'est ce
qui est plus chiant d'abord on va
demander les tests ci a pas de tests ya
pas de tournage l'était c'est tous les
quinze jours et on ne demande pas juste
le test du coc vide ou du vih
on demande toute une panoplie de tel
donc nous les cotons-tiges vous si vide
qui les prenait depuis un an
ça fait dix ans qu'on les prend
[Musique]